[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast for
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Brett and I'm Elkhound
snuggle baby what
I'm linked this week on the round table
a dim lights on it we're throwing down
on the story is that a DJ pun yep yep
yep I speak on the table I speak
differently as a DJ
um this week we're throwing down the
knowledge tossing down the knowledge I
am regaling the development
the highs and let me tell you the lows
of becoming a DJ and developing
and revealing my Persona are you sure
you don't want to just make this into a
book
like right now this is your last chance
because we have things the highs and
lows of Elkhound snuggle but if you
think about the hierarchy or the way
that we we do our lives we've got
stories that begin and then stop because
they need to be reserved for the podcast
but we might be in a stories that need
to be reserved for your memoir
and so you know but I I need to be
recording those I would do I'm going to
do it on this podcast you can do both of
them you think you can do that oh yeah I
can do both okay all right this could be
in the book I it's it's like I can have
two DJ names that are one I can do both
right it's true
so is this L count speaking now or
snuggle baby
um this is elcon snuggle baby speaking
to you
okay all right so when you say it you
just say it like that El count snuggle
baby
you don't say I'll count snuggle baby
I have not put the pause no okay but I'm
glad you're so interested in the in the
details because I'm gonna have to get
into all those I yeah a lot of people
are asking how I came up with the name
you know there's the whole look my my
get up that I debuted at mythicon on the
last night at the dance party
and
um I'm really curious as I talked to you
about last week of just like we haven't
talked about your perspective on all of
it there was a lot of it that I was
developing independently and um you know
it there's also there's another layer to
this which is
but just like the creative journey of
developing something new
that in some ways in many ways maybe in
all the ways you experienced with James
and the shame that I think is kind of a
I'll call it a b story here today so if
you don't like DJing if you're not into
Persona development and what I mean who
isn't I don't know what your problem is
I mean DJing but if you're not into
Persona development right then who are
is there anyone who was ever like on a
dating profile specifically not into
Persona development not anyone I've
dated conceptually not anyone I've
swiped in the direction that means I am
interested I don't know which direction
I've never swiped either way
um but yeah there's that b story of
stepping out of your comfort zone taking
a creative risk and then seeing what
happens
um definitely my my DJ launch experience
and some of the stuff I'll tell you
about afterward
uh
it's it's it definitely is has been
uncomfortable at times and I think it's
been very good it's been very edifying
you know I'm just trying to take in all
parts of this experience and just milk
the teeth for all it's worth just I'm
milking the DJ teat dry and I'm it turns
out I'm rapidly experiencing just a full
range of emotions oh wow associated with
it so that's kind of what's going on
here too
um should we just get into it I mean why
am I calling myself as a DJ Elkhound
snuggle baby but do not put DJ in front
of it and dude don't do that and do put
snuggle baby
in parentheses Elkhound one word space
open parentheses parenthesis parenthesis
parenthesis and I worked on this uh
snuggle baby all one word closed
parenthesis
the only thing I'll say at this moment
is that I feel like I've had I've had
some independent parallel experiences
um that will inform my are informing my
perspective as we get to those places
where you tell those parts of the story
but I mean I feel like just last night
and I'll keep this very brief
I had an experience a DJ witnessing
experience not like I tried to share the
Lord with a DJ you witnessed it I
witnessed a DJ okay
um uh you know one of my kind I got to
go to the Orville Peck uh concert in
Orville invited me to the this is fine
this was the the final uh the final show
of the tour in La invited me to the
after party uh and Jesse and I went and
we showed up and there was a DJ it was
like kind of a house that's also a club
in Hollywood and there was a woman who
was DJing and women can DJ keeping it
pretty uh I wasn't saying anything I was
just specifying so that that felt an
inappropriate but
um she was kind of just kind of keeping
it kind of chill and then a dude came in
and Jesse leans over to me and she's
like why is that guy like leaning in and
seeming to begin to kind of like intrude
on This Woman's DJ space and I looked up
and I said because that's Diplo
so at that point
I uh which I would say we're cut from
the same ill so as it Blow as a DJ this
guy's what top you know well he's he's
in the top he's cream of the crop DJ
right yeah
um so I was like having witnessed the
birth
of el count snuggle baby yeah and it's
his first Adventure you know I haven't
really watched the DJ before until I
watched Ella count snuggle baby and so
so now I've got a parallel experience to
sort of when we get to that I'll just
give you some of mine yeah I definitely
want to be compared to Diplo at this
point in my career like that is exactly
it was just an interesting
juxtapositionally fair I feel like the
universe is giving me because I don't
know what you're saying no I'm saying
that I don't clarify I'm saying anything
I learn about DJing is now I have a I
have a vessel that I can I can I can
send it to okay good if I learned
something about DJing in my everyday
life I give it to all kind of snuggle
baby that's my mission I did tell Diplo
that if he wants to show up any of my
sets he can lean in and give a little
squishy scratch he will he'll lean in
and eventually he'll take over
completely uh what does a DJ
name his child
this is a joke that Lando told me this
morning because he Now talks to be as if
I'm elk count snuggle baby
D Junior
no
DJ names his child
Eric oh that's much better yeah that's
good yeah what is a DJ order at an
Italian restaurant
okay no
no no no no
okay some words work better than others
yeah
[Music]
uh just marinero that's an odd order
I mean let's see okay so how did I come
up with the name
um
well
you know you you were you were
encouraging me you were like I you no
did you yeah I know you're you said
you're gonna do this DJ set
you need to go like you need to go all
the way like don't don't just half-ass
it like unless you need to make this a
moment you know to your credit you gave
me the encouragement I needed at just
the right time like a month ahead of
mythicon probably I'd been I'd been
thinking about my set I'd been working
on it I'll talk about that a little bit
but
well I'll just say that like I was I was
pretty nervous about it and I so
I didn't at the point that we had that
conversation I didn't have a lot of
confidence now I'm implying I got a lot
of confidence later maybe I did I don't
know
um
and you had that conversation with me
and I was talking about how I'm
practicing and how I'm kind of nervous
about it
and that's when you gave me the input of
like well you need to make it a moment
it's the end of mythicon you need to
make a big reveal about I mean you're
saying what your name is but you need to
have a look to go along with it and I
was like I had thought about it but I I
just wasn't
I don't know I I think I was so nervous
about it that I was scared that if I
fully committed in my mind to making it
a thing
especially publicly that like people
could take pictures of me and it would
be worth sharing because of the way I
looked and that then
um that I would be building it up too
much that it I'm just starting out DJing
and it would seem like I thought I was
the [ __ ] when really I'm just a
fledgling DJ person you know and so I
was wrestling with that but I was like
you know what
he's right I gotta I gotta go for it and
so I started throwing out some of my
thoughts which were
yeah I do need to have a get up my but I
don't want to wear a helmet you know all
of these DJs wear helmets Yeah the Daft
punks of the world the dead mouses of
the world uh the marshmallows and
um
Etc
I don't want to cover this face because
anybody who wants they want to know it's
me any mythical Beast who's showing up
at this particular show and I was
thinking more about the first show than
like like my long career into the
distant future as a DJ which may happen
hopefully it will
um sounds like I don't want to come
people want you know people want to see
my face because they don't want to they
came to see me DJ yeah and I also don't
want to mess with my hair you know my
hair is put it's attached to my face at
the top and it's something I really like
my hair you know it's part of it's part
of my signature right
so then I'm like well
ah
what could I
do and then like I was thinking antlers
I think you were part of this
conversation you might have thrown out
antlers too but I was definitely
thinking that I was like yes it's a
mythical tie-in
um but like not like the animals need to
be big so then it was it it got to Elk
pretty quick there was like a moose
thought
and then it was like you know what most
antlers are like they're real like big
hands satellite dishes almost yeah
they're like satellite dishes that that
could definitely work it's definitely
big
and I was like but I knew that elk have
these magnificent antlers that are more
deer-like and seem pretty cool so I'm
like I bet you I could do something like
that and then instead of it attaching
to my head
I was out because I was uncomfortable
what if there was some sort of like
shoulder Mount that then the antlers
would come up and they would be behind
my head
came up with all this before really
coming up with a DJ name the look and
then that that's what led to all right
uh elk you know we we we're talking
about elk handlers
and then I remembered
um my mom had a dog that was a Norwegian
Elkhound actually it was before I was
born when my mom and dad were together
they had a dog that was a Norwegian
Elkhound Named Sam it's a Norwegian
Elkhound is a beautiful dog that
according to some tweets after I put my
moniker out there people were telling me
like these dogs I guess they
they heard elk and they will run between
the legs of Galloping elk of course my
mom and dad my dad was a farmer at the
time and my mom worked like a medical
facility and there were no elk anywhere
in the region that dog is very
disappointed but the dog would run all
over the farm and just come back at the
end of the day it was just like it I've
I have pictures what happened to this
dog and the divorce you know what I I
need to ask him to set it free I I think
the dog stayed on the farm I can't quite
remember
but the dog was special to Mom and
beautiful like black and white fur
kind of husky like
um so I was like
Elkhound I like that name for a DJ
better than just like elk that just
seems like that's just a word
and then I'm like
so L count yeah that's that that's good
that's it that could be it but that's
not enough and then I'm like I need four
more so that's not enough it it wasn't
enough because then I was concerned that
if I call myself Elkhound then people
might think that that's just cool
that's a cool name for a DJ that DJ
better be good
it's kind of what I was thinking at the
time but really just that DJ that's a
cool name
maybe it sounds like this person who
calls himself that is taking himself too
seriously
I want to add something to it that
presents a different side because
Elkhound is like it's it's Elkhound it's
percussive it could almost be abrasive
it could almost be
um kind of emphatic in your face like
that's what that word feels like
Elkhound it's like it hits hard so then
I want something to soften the edges I
want something that gives a different
but complementary
energy
and I also want something that when
people have to say it
because when you come up with a name you
basically there's a lot of power in a
name you know when people name kids
happens a lot every time someone has one
they seem to name it that's a lot of
power it's becoming less common though
you're becoming less common you you're
you're dictating what will flow from the
lips of everyone that interacts with
this person
and so it's wielding some sort of power
over them I recognize that and I wanted
to use that power for smiles
so I decided that
I wanted to add
the first thing that came to my mind
when I put all this criteria together oh
that was the first one was
snuggle baby
because
and I I liked the idea of people having
to call me snuggle baby and try to do it
with a straight face it just seemed very
link
that's for sure and like unexpected I
think we're all in agreement on that and
then when you put that together
It's a combination of words that doesn't
exist so when you're talking about
buying a website domain or like trying
to get the tick tock moniker what is it
whatever it's called the username on
Twitter and Instagram I Twitter and
Instagram I don't know if you could fit
it's Elkhound snug okay yeah but on Tick
Tock it's Elkhound snuggle baby
are you gonna actually use those I don't
know yet use those feel free to follow
them uh I because I created them for
James and the shame and then I was like
I'm gonna do this I just want to own
them yeah yeah I do already so it's like
because Elkhound that's already been
taken it's a freaking dog
I could have just been snuggle baby
I I think I did find one account that
was a
um like a
foot fetish
account
that nobody followed
and I'm not snuggle baby yeah
thank you for pointing that out well if
you search for it if you find the foot
fetish snuggle baby that's not me
but and I kind of I was like I feel good
about this
and then I believe you were the first
person I told
because what we had a creative house
when I told you because you were the one
who was like well you got to put snuggle
baby in parentheses
and I'm like and I stand by I'm like
yeah I mean like well I don't have to
put it in parentheses it's like but you
can't but you but you agreed the first
thing that I liked about the suggestion
was it's uh it's kind of like if you're
if you're a true hip-hop fan you know
that MF Doom has to always be presented
in all caps
and so I like
that kind of test and that's why I had
to like go on record on Twitter and like
be very adamant about how it was spelled
because hey there it is
if you know you know I'm not going to
keep and I reiterated at the beginning
of this but you know what I'm not going
to do that anymore
I'm not going to do that anymore at one
point I was thinking I was never going
to write it at all and people were just
gonna have to say open parentheses close
parentheses but that was stupid
um but I did like that idea of it being
like if you know you know and you also
seem to spell it
um and it was just weird but you also
seem to embrace the fact because
basically what I the reason I suggested
that is because when you described it
and then because you basically gave you
gave your reasoning that you just gave
me which is like yeah I'm there's L
count but and that might just be cool uh
exactly what you just said and so to me
it's it kind of sounded like there is
this sort of exterior shell that people
may interact with which is Elkhound
um and then there is this if you know
you know the sort of the Interior
snuggle baby and it's like for because
for me oh this gives you these this
flexibility so you're saying that the
parentheses become like a womb
I wasn't suggesting or picturing a womb
you can do that if you want all I'm
saying is that because you seem to
embrace this I'm not going to give it
away because I want to hear what your
process was
even during your set yeah well that came
to light later which I think I thought
that was a really good application of it
because yeah in my mind it could be like
at this party elk counts showing up and
that's all you got to me it was like
it's two people in one one's a little
bit more if you know you know but it
just gives you this flexibility and also
yeah it's kind of weird and funny I
definitely have developed it as more of
like a Jekyll and Hyde two sides of a
coin Persona two for the price of one
birds in the hand and maybe at some
point as you evolve uh because you are
an animal and animals undergo Evolution
and so do people because people are
animals you could actually update your
suit so that when you when you there's
actually a transformation that takes
place during a show I mean it's just
like I just feel like there's so many
people so many possibilities yeah it
kind of hinges on becoming a good DJ
that is probably yeah which I am excited
about but I will tell you
It Ain't Easy
um one just some words about my costume
Elise who's a friend of Mark Byers who
produced a lot of our music
um uh actually Mike Paisley introduced
me to her because he was so busy and
Jesse was so busy building all the stuff
from mythicon that they didn't have any
capacity to build my uh my DJ outfit so
uh I got a lease in on the action so she
designed it for me we went with like a
viking Motif that was like a rugged it's
it's less if I'm an animal and more of
like I'm it's kind of like you killed a
viking Garb type thing with the way the
stuff that's on the wrapped around the
antlers there's like some Flair on it
and then there's like a shoulder draped
um
Cape like a a fur a fur drape
and if you think that my shoulders look
big under there it's not because I'm
wearing shoulder pads it's just because
I am that I'm that buff and the and
there are shoulder pads under there oh
okay thank you that got kind of it gets
kind of hot so I had to wear a tank top
and shorts I noticed so that my I ended
my Ensemble by wearing like
um some small corduroy shorts and then
um tennis shoes and uh
crew socks
so it's kind of dadish yeah I had that
Vantage Point yeah you got to be behind
my deck for that
um I want to take a quick just second
just to acknowledge that when this comes
out it's freaking Cyber Monday tomorrow
and so all those starting right now
there's so many sales happening we've
had over at mythical.com and also
mythical society.com okay these are some
of the deals that started on Friday and
then continue through tomorrow if you're
watching this as it comes out
20 off site-wide 20 off site 40 off
Psych products 40 off psych uh and we've
also got a new product GMM ornaments you
should get those soon if you want to get
we had ornaments last year that were us
this year we got some amazing new
mythical ornaments uh mythical
society.com we've got 20 off monthly
first and second degree memberships 30
off monthly third degree memberships
so mythical.com mythical.com
mythical society.com incredible deals
get it while they last Cyber Monday I I
DJing really suits me I think I've told
you this before I might have talked
about on the podcast but like I
I bought a deck like over the pandemic I
had uh signed up for master class just
so I could take Quest loves master class
on DJ which turned out to not be that
technical but it was more like an
overview so it was like a really cool
primer to just start to understand
yeah and um you know
I think yeah that happened before I was
like stepped into the role of DJing the
Christmas in July party here at mythical
but I only have my La I only had Spotify
I didn't have any
real means to actually DJ and I learned
so many things about it that I told you
about that necessitated me buying a DJ
deck like I bought a used one off eBay
so that it's interesting this my
psychology along the way it's good for
me to notice this in myself because I
don't it's something to overcome
um
if if someone's trying something
creative kind of like me but like as I
would I would rationalize things like
I'm not gonna buy a deck new
um because then I'll feel bad when I
don't follow through with this so I'm
gonna buy a used one-off eBay so I won't
feel as bad if I walk away from this
it's something you know it was like I
was giving myself out in for instead of
like saying you know what
I think I could be really into this I'm
going to go for it at so many buy
something so new and expensive that
you'll feel guilty if you stop that's
what I would have done you know you're
like right like like guilt yourself into
not stopping right I kind of had this
predisposition oh this probably won't
turn in anything I'm going to encounter
something that's going to be the reason
that like I just never follow through
with it and that's why I like
when I even when I was doing mythicon I
was like I'm not going to make a big
deal out of this you know it's it's not
a healthy Instinct I think it's
something that I've had to overcome and
that's why I just I'm going back trying
to acknowledge it because I'm learning
from it
um
but I I just really started getting into
I love music I love listening to music
like especially over the pandemic I got
really into it so then like being able
to manipulate music and turn knobs
there's like a the editor in me
um and I'm talking like video editor of
me that I don't do anymore it's like
that really
came to that came back to me like using
the using the deck it's just a lot of
Spotlight making playlists for I love
making for certain to set Vibes yeah
yeah and uh greatest compliment you can
give me is cannot have that can I have
the playlist you were playing
um so
as I started getting ready for mythicon
I was like I kept I just didn't
there's two things it's like working on
what songs You're Gonna Play and then
working on the skills of a DJ to be able
to like operate the deck and transition
between songs and put things in an order
kind of make it seamless and once you
start watching tutorials and reading
about stuff it gets overwhelming really
quickly
and
at that point Ben here at work are you
know DP director on a lot of stuff he
was like you know I gotta tell you I got
a DJ deck
um recently too I was like really
I was like dude we should get together
and like
do some DJ double DJ so it was like
three weeks before mythica that we
finally were able to get together and
Ben is you know very technical and uh so
when he he had all these things to show
me that I had not figured out and so
over the course of a few hours of him
like showing me some Transitions and he
had his own deck and he would show me
stuff and then he would try to figure
out how to do it on his deck oh my Dad
how's his deck compared to yours he got
a bigger deck his deck is uh not as good
as mine oh okay but he probably paid
more because I got mine used okay well
interesting
um
so he was he was teaching me things I
didn't know which is pretty much
everything
and I just I'll tell you and I don't I
don't know how much ben I don't know
what his perspective on it was but like
when when we parted ways that night I
stayed there for another three hours
freaking out and trying to practice
because I was like oh my God I didn't
realize how much I didn't know and now
I'm gonna suck so bad well had you been
like before Ben showed up were you like
I was putting together a playlist and
like practicing Transitions and stuff
like what was like
I know so little about about how this
works from a technical perspective I
don't know anything about it I had to
you gotta pick a bunch of songs and from
the reading I did it's like
however long your set is you need to
have three times that amount of songs so
I'm like I need to be ready to do two
hours at mythicon now that reduced some
but two so at the time I was thinking I
need six hours of music
if I'm if I'm transitioning so explain
that to people because when you play
when you're reading the room you have to
be able to go with the flow of what's
happening if you're not connecting with
an audience you've got to change it up
you got to be able to go in a different
direction like a different style you
have to like
um and I have kind of an Eclectic style
like I like some pop stuff like I'm a
fan of the Harry Styles album
um I like to play some Dua Lipa but then
I'm a real hip-hop guy so I really like
that and I like old school hip-hop and I
like some a lot of new hip-hop but if
people aren't into that and they don't
know the new stuff then I've only got
the old stuff and I can't keep going
back and within any one song if it gets
a little boring you kind of wanna
transition to a new song
I mean if a song is five minutes or four
minutes
in that in a certain in a dance setting
yeah I don't think you want to sometimes
you just don't want to play more than
like half of it yeah you know you want
to keep things moving like the moment
they start to get a little okay
I'm everybody's not loving this song you
got to move on and then you got to
figure out a way to do it
that is as seamless as possible right
you know so you can move from one thing
to the next so I understand all these
principles like I know
I know how to read a room I have my
taste in music I only want to play
things that I like that then also
connect with people
so
I I had all these exercises in my mind
that was like song selection matters so
much and then technique like beat
matching where you you have a song and
then you cue up another song in your
earphones and you match the beat so like
you move the tempo up or down to be in
sync with the other song and then you
find a way to start playing it and
mixing the two together and then
subtly transitioning in a way that seems
like you've done sort of a remix and
that's why DJ has like headphones that
are like one ear on when they're when
they're all you're listening to what the
crowd's hearing but then you're
listening what you're queuing up and
playing because like you don't want this
long intro oh yeah this is an album cut
and like the artist is talking or doing
a skit or something this is like you're
gonna kill the room if you gotta start
it at the right time
so all of these and there's so much more
that I still don't know but in terms of
being able to transition I mean and then
you can do like key matching because you
don't want to be blending stuff that are
in different Keys it'll be like
dissonant and it doesn't it just is like
eh
there's so much technique that goes into
it that I'm just scratching the surface
but
I made up my mind in the limited amount
of time I had I was like I cannot and it
was that night that I kind of decided I
cannot put this much pressure on myself
to like be
a technically proficient DJ I just I'm
not there yet if but I can't lose sight
of some key
realities
um the first is there is this is going
to be the most supportive enthusiastic
crowd to just and a lot of them will
know the story that I'm telling like the
where this that I'm just getting started
with this right and all they want to do
is just watch me try this new Endeavor
and support me through it it was there
probably won't be a gathering
to watch
I'll I'll just skip ahead and tell you
based on my experience there was not I
don't think there is a DJ whose first
public set was in such a supportive
enthusiastic environment yeah ever it
may be the most it was the supportive
day most awesome yeah crowd for a DJ who
was just getting started
it was amazing I was actually watching I
was right about the uh the DJ who
started the night
yeah and I was like I was good I was
like trying to get his his read on
things I actually he was playing it
really close to the vest I couldn't
get much of a read but I could on what
online his read of the crowd or on the
couch on the fact that like because he
was kind of down there in the back kind
of hanging out in the back oh while I
was up there while you were up there and
I'm like here's this guy that's been
playing for the crowd and the crowd is
really into it already right I mean I'm
sure he had been educated on like you
know I was really self-conscious coming
up today yeah there was a DJ who played
and warmed up the crowd because when our
when our stage show ended everybody made
their way to the tent and the DJ started
playing the dance party started and then
after like 45 minutes is when I came on
and took over
and well and like literally I walked on
and then he walked off and specifically
and then he watched and I was really
selfish well let's get into the details
of like how you actually started the set
like what that involved because that was
what was a trip to a to uh to be there
to witness so yeah but also to then like
turn and watch this guy because like you
didn't have it this is what I wanted it
wasn't a typical uh introduction
on any level nope
but the the just to finish my thought
though that the second point was I
they're going to be supported with the
first point second point that I wanted
to keep in the Forefront of my mind is
that like I'm not going to focus on
technique I'm just going to focus on
song selection if at the end of the day
I play a song
all the way through and then I play the
next song all the way through I can just
do that and it will be okay it song
selection is so much more important
than any technique at this point in the
game for me
so I spent a lot of time like amassing
playlist private playlist that like got
me to six hours of music
and then I then I just started working
on putting that playlist together in an
order and saying
you know you set cue points so if you
need to skip forward in a song you can
skip forward on beat and it won't feel
like I'm just guessing at when I
transition to the next song If You Can
skip to the kind of the outro of the
song and then transition it becomes a
little easier and then
but so that was my focus and then once I
got my set list down then I did start
just trying to get proficient at going
from song to song it sounds simple but I
was just like I just have to keep it
simple
but then I also wanted
I was like well
I have to reveal my DJ name the first
time anyone's gonna hear it is going to
be from stage and well I'm like see DJs
I know they can talk but like in the
purest form in my opinion a DJ doesn't
talk but I need to talk because I need
to say what my DJ name is
so I said you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to
record
little sounds I'm going to record a
little little little moments that
announce my DJ name
so
you know I I actually got I actually got
Mark over
and uh he recorded he recorded me
and then we like put some effects on
some stuff that like then I could load
it on my deck and like hit a hit buttons
and start playing
stuff
that would you know reveal my DJ name so
like this Elkhound
snuggle baby
that's my voice
I remember hearing that Elkhound
snuggle baby now in in a large tent with
a lot of people making a lot of noise
um there was a lot of this as this began
to happen this is my vantage point well
hold on and let me tell you how it
happened okay so I said well I'm just
not going to get up there and start
playing these sound effects I've got I I
need an intro track so I had like music
that I came out to like a wrestler
instrumental
kind of like Viking with a big beat
music and then when that was over
I did just I hit him with an elk Hound
Elkhound
and then I hit him with a snuggle baby
snuggle baby
and I knew at this point that people
were going to be like what yeah
lots of leaning over first of all a lot
of cheering I mean
ear chattering oh my God deafening
cheers because they were reacting to my
antlers and my freaking fur cake but
then a lot of people were like
Greg who at that point was getting ready
for like the inaugural tweet
he leans over to me and he's like how do
you what is it elk Eltron
Eltron L train I heard L train from
people and I was like elk helmed and I
and I and I want to take full
responsibility for
not including the parentheses in the
mythical because he was like how do you
spell that and I was like it's Elkhound
and the snuggle baby and obviously I was
team parentheses but
I think it it created a great way for
you to clarify it I
got up there and then I
I hit him with the elk count and the
snuggle baby and then I
I had recorded I was like I I don't want
to give a speech
but I just felt like
um
I felt like I needed to give a speech
but I didn't want to give a speech so I
I called Jenna
and I said I need you to come over here
for I'm recording some stuff I need your
voice because I know you were the voice
of an alien in Independence Day she's
the voice of the orb yeah well
I thought it was AI but it she explained
to me as an alien it's a singularity of
a whole in Independence Day two yes
independent oh Independence Day two oh
yeah yeah yeah okay you told me all this
when we were recording because I was
wrong about it I thought you were AI
You're an Alien Singularity you recorded
the scratch track because you worked for
the director and then they loved it so
much that they just kept you in the
movie they did they did not recast from
your scratch try so I was like I need
your voice
so I had her come in and record ad-lib
speech now wow ad-lib speech I've never
heard you make that effect
see I'm doing a little DJing right now
ad-lib speech now yeah and then I
in there in there Jenna was sitting over
there Mark was recording me I ad-lib to
speak yeah so that was evident and so
then I I said well I'm just gonna play
the speech for people and I'm going I
recorded it it was uh two minutes and 41
seconds long
um
and I decided it would be hilarious if I
play the speech
and then I start gesturing as if I'm
actually giving the speech like I'm an
animatronic version
of a DJ and like the Hall of Presidents
at Disney yeah I just thought that would
be awesome yeah so I started this speech
and then after a while I stopped
pantomiming and I started I I faded in a
beat underneath it to make it seem
cooler right even though that that was
uh on the Fly decision no I'd plan to do
it but it wasn't in a trap natural I had
to do it I had to fade it up so like
this like
um
sizza I faded in some sizza yeah that's
always a good idea I'm not gonna play
the the whole speech for you but I'll
play a little bit so L count snuggle
baby
that's that's my DJ name this is me
yo I'm not well I don't think I'm I'm
not really gonna say yo I I don't I
think I'm just gonna say things that I
would normally say of like my normal
life
but this is this is kind of this is but
I could go in full Persona and I guess
as a DJ you know what let's meet halfway
just call me Elkhound
snuggle baby you know
yeah you know then I know that we'll be
on the same page
um and then that was playing that was
like 30 yeah it was 20 seconds there's
still two minutes of speech left but
there's music I put music underneath so
it was like everyone was just kind of
like understanding
this is the most awkward speech
that is completely ad-libbed like
there's it's not edited in any way this
is exactly what I really I did an ad-lib
speech and then I didn't like it
oh so this is a take two this is take
two oh but it's totally different than
take one
really different concept I went a
different direction
so yeah I recorded this ad-lib speech
didn't edit any of it threw some effects
on it and then I was like I'll just
bring some some uh some scissor
underneath it you know
and uh yeah so there's two minutes left
you want me to keep playing the whole
thing it's awkward
you know I wanted to capture the
aquidity of
the moment like just this thing is like
I'm calling myself this you know if if
you are willing to call me elk count
snuggle baby that says something about
our relationship because if you're
willing to call me that
and that says something about our
relationships like there's that I just
don't think
anybody off the street will be
comfortable looking me in the eyes and
calling me Elkhound snuggle baby it's
just such a it's the thing that normal
people wouldn't do right like if
somebody asked me to do that look them
in the eyes and call an Elkhound snuggle
baby I would be like
um I'm gonna order coffee from somewhere
else you know and Jenna you're sitting
there while this is happening
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
because because
um later on you know she had to be the
one to record Elkhound mode yeah that
was one of my favorite Parts yeah and
then of course she also recorded snuggle
baby mode
yeah
and then she also recorded L counts
doing business as snuggle baby
yeah that's pretty you're welcome I like
that that's my favorite one L counts
doing business as snuggle baby yeah
because
I determined that like Elkhound mode was
like we're going for it we're getting
down and then snuggle baby mode is more
of like oh man I'm I'm kind of having
some feelings to go along with it I was
trying to and the video goes more like
to like 90. you were trying to figure
out the difference
it wasn't immediately obvious to me it's
more snuggle baby's more laid back and
in other I couldn't go and honestly I
didn't I never went into full snuggle
baby mode which would be more of slow
jams very not not too sexy but just very
laid back like almost like Lounge Bob
your head kind of a thing maybe stroke
something could be a pet okay all right
uh and then outcome mode you're like
gonna be sore the next day
if there's moshing that's going to
happen it's going to be without count
right the the one that I never got to
play because I didn't have enough pads
oh count snuggle baby
e-l-k-h-o-u-n-d open parenthesis
s-n-u-g-g-l-e-b-a-b-y close parenthesis
yeah that's probably a good choice that
you I I chose a little bit I thought you
didn't like that one you have the proper
spelling I like your delivery it was a
little overbearing I'm questioning my
entire life that's the one I used that
was and I'm glad you used that I'm
questioning my entire life and you use
that pretty liberally that is when I
first started recording it was an honest
reaction this was honestly one of the
first things that I said when recording
I'm questioning my entire life right now
so now that's part of my that's the
signature tag for elkcon well okay so
let me interject at this point these are
all my sound about I'm good to go I feel
like what this represents uh at this
point including that one that you just
said and I think that last one I'm
questioning my entire life right now
really illustrates this and I think it
is
it also speaks to the fact to the
environment in which you did this and
that is
um and I think this is a beautiful thing
so
your apprehensiveness
associated with this endeavor and you're
questioning yourself
I'm questioning my entire life right now
it is
it's a part of the introduction yes you
know what I'm saying so it's just like
in that I wanted to bring my honest self
to it and I think I think you success
well you succeeded like you got all of
me and I think that's you know first of
all I you know it's an overused term
that we are that authenticity is valued
in entertainment and I think that the
internet and specifically social media
and social media entertainment like
YouTube Etc
has it's the reason
honestly
it's the reason that we do this podcast
now in the way that we do it it's the
reason that we shared our deconstruction
stories which is the reason that I made
the album about deconstruction real man
it's there's a real leaning into the
like I I I'm I could put on errors and
try to appear to be something or
whatever but this is actually my
authentic self you wrapped that
into the actual presentation itself and
I made it performance art so it was at
this that's when I started to really get
excited was I'm taking some risk in
something that can't be compared to
anything else like I'm doing something
that I want people to scratch their
heads I want them to feel weird and but
it's like people were so supportive I
don't even think they felt those things
and that's what that second part of that
is you can only kind of do that in a
really supportive place it's almost like
no I will do it anywhere well but I'm
saying for the first time but yes uh you
created what you might call a director's
commentary that you would then see in
the
documentary about your DJ debut but you
folded it into the actual debut itself
if that makes sense this is the
director's commentary
you see me up there on stage I was
questioning my entire life but no you're
just like I'm questioning my entire life
right now I don't know how many people
I'm people like I think most people
experienced it as link is very weird and
very odd and I'm not surprised and
that's everything that I expected and so
that kind of makes this fun and cool and
enjoyable which it did but I think
probably some people were like oh he's
it is performance art but it's honest
performance art I when I went up there
on that stage
um
I was not nervous I went from three
weeks earlier to being in complete wreck
to determining that with my criteria and
like you know that like I wasn't going
to lose perspective and I was not gonna
let go of my insistence on having the
time of my life
and I am so I I've never had anything
that I felt so much pressure and then
got past it so that when it happened
I could just be just
there for it and let me tell you I
I actually that was my experience and
we've done a lot of stuff that I wish I
could go back and be able to pull that
mind trick
and but something about the setting was
so special that the safety net was so
supportive yeah that it it's not I you
know it's unrealistic to expect that I
could go back and apply it
100 percent to Something in the past or
even in the future for like our next
demanding thing that like because you
know there was also like nothing really
depends on this you know it's like if I
fall flat on my face I'm just gonna get
up and keep going and make a joke
because once we got past all of this
stuff
like this opening part I still didn't
speak the entire
set I just started playing
my set and I had a decent number I had a
bunch of ideas for how I wanted to
transition stuff
and I would say
um a third of the time I
I pretty much accomplished what I was
going for a third of the time
okay and I think that a lot of things
like
you know a lot of times it I would just
I'd hit the button and I would say like
Bell count snuggle babe yeah well
over half the time that I played
Elkhound I was trying to cue the next
song in my headphones okay and then it
did often come at interesting times yeah
it was never he's making some
interesting choices yeah I was like
because because I listen on my headphone
and I'm queuing up the song and you
can't hear that but somehow the yeah
well it still goes out there or snuggle
baby oh I just said Elkhound by accident
I better say snuggle baby now and then I
would hit snuggle baby and then I would
cue up my thing and then they gotta
cheer every time you gotta cheer every
time and it got to a point where I was
like oh I'm screwing up and if y'all
just act like I meant to do it after
that intro that I gave they're going to
believe that I'm meant to do everything
like even when I played the speech like
after like 45 seconds into the speech
I accidentally started the speech over
yeah I thought that was intentional and
I was like oh that's uh yeah that's a
weird Choice I'm going on Instinct now I
guess my body wanted that to be even
weirder than it was so I gave the speech
twice the first half of the speech twice
um and then it was it was weird maybe I
just got looser I got some confidence
but
there were a couple of points towards
the end of the set like I was going to
go from Michael McDonald
I keep forgetting
into
uh regulate
by you know the G-funk classic which
samples it
and I could not get
regulate to play I couldn't I don't I
still don't know you don't know what
happened I couldn't transition to the
next song and that's why like I keep
forgetting it went away to nothing
people people would always cheer because
they you know it was like oh he's going
in the next song that she'd be so
gracious and then I'm like struggling to
figure out why this song's not playing
and then I end up having to go back and
just play more of Michael McDonald
because I couldn't figure out how to get
to it I was like well okay I just move
on and then and that was in the latter
half of the set and then the next like
so by the time we got to the ending like
I had
the other thing was things got squirrely
because I had so much music but I had I
had like an hour of music I wanted to
play and I had 15 minutes to play it so
I had to start making choices of what I
was thinking noise ordinance that we had
to abide by well yeah at a certain point
you just gotta wrap it up it was I mean
it was after midnight
and so I'm making all these choices on
the Fly And then trying to figure out
how I'm going to transition from song to
song between songs I've never it's never
I've never I'm I'm literally doing
everything in the moment and that that's
what got the best of me that when I like
these fundamental mistakes like oh this
slide is over here so this song is never
they're never gonna hear this song so
the set kind of started to fall apart a
little bit by the end but
um and then at the very end I did get
the microphone and I gave a speech and I
was like you know what all good things
must come to an end thanks for coming
out to mythicon this has been amazing
and then I I pressed I had it all queued
up and I I was press I was gonna play
the last song roll out yep so that
everybody could leave Yeah by ludicrous
wouldn't play yeah I am it would not
place that when you started saying I
can't get the last song to play yeah
that's when I said I I I would end this
if I could get the last song to play the
beautiful thing about your style
anything could be intentional anything
or unintentionally no one knows Yes
except for now yeah now they know so now
when people come to my sets they're
gonna be like oh it must all be a
mistake yeah right but nope I'm gonna
get better it's all going to be
intentional and then I finally got roll
out to play and then when rollout was
over
I had one more song queued up like my
walk-off song
and I pressed it nothing happened and I
just walked off stage yeah and it was
just like I was like this has been
amazing I'm not gonna let any of this
get to me and I was ecstatic but there
was some in my mind there were some huge
fails but the biggest thing about it was
I was up there on stage and I was like
in I was in this world of like okay I'm
gonna get started I didn't have my
headphones
so like right at the beginning I'm like
yeah there's a lot of details I lean
over to I lean over and like Jenna walks
up and right you walked up and Ben
walked out well I could see
I was like I could tell by the body
language that something was wrong right
I was like I was looking DJ on his
headphones I was looking at the other
deed that the other dj's headphones and
their his Jacks were too big because
he's a he's a big time DJ he's got an
eighth inch yeah I didn't want to say
how big his deck was but his deck was
twice as big as maybe four times okay
yeah and his Jacks were twice as big in
my Jack so I leaned over to Jen and I
was like I need my headphones bones
they're in my computer bag in the other
house in the top and then come to find
out Jenna Sprints over there and I I
started the speech so I'm doing the
speech now and then Jenna when you came
back you fell flat on your face oh I ate
it oh bad yeah I sprinted all the way to
the house I like there were some crew
members in there and I was like
emergency other way
and I like grabbed her headphones
sprinted all the way back and then bound
up the stairs and I hit the last stair
to the stage and just bam in front of
everybody in front of everybody ate it
straight down I did not see this oh
silicon snuggle baby was in his own
world because I was giving my speech I
was giving my speech Jenna was following
her your headphones were like silver
there it is Christie's headphones from
going on planes how big were they oh
they're like Bose headphones yeah for
some reason I can't picture them but
then I'm
looking around and the crew is on stage
uh Lily's on stage Lincoln's on stage my
dad is on stage they're all dancing
Christy's on stage you know Christy's
not in the public eye she made a choice
that she was going to be out there
supporting me and it was just a it it
was so sweet it was it was beautiful you
were on stage I was David Hill was like
my hype man over on the other side David
Hill has a gift oh my God I can't go
anywhere without that guy now he is
amazing
and like when I played new light which
is like me and Lily and Lincoln's song
like they came over and put my arms
around them and we're dancing that's
also not something you typically see at
a DJ set is it something like the DJ's
kids yeah come up and dance with him but
again I was thinking that at the time I
was like
what oh interesting I I was just I've
been thinking about tell me what you
thought about the whole thing that you
well I I was thinking
the way that it was a great culmination
to
mythicon in general because I was like
what an interesting world that
you know the two of us and our team and
the mythical beasts have created in
which this what is happening right now
is possible like you
your dad from Myrtle North Myrtle Beach
South Carolina is up there like dancing
doing his his dance dancing a jig to jid
uh
and
you know on the same stage where the
night before I Jesse and I had done this
country music thing wild man for the
same essentially the same group of
people and then your kids are up there
my shepherd's up there like Shepherd's
up there Shepard's trying to get to
dance a little bit it was awesome um and
I was just like this yeah I I I was
so in terms of in terms of that I was
just like what a interest what an
incredible atmosphere for this kind of
thing to happen
um and then
I mean ultimately I was I was thinking
this is
I don't think anything that you did was
surprising I think that all of it was I
didn't know none of it I I've learned
was expected that if you couldn't have
expected anything if you had to ask me
what mistakes did you make
that I picked up on I would be like
well obviously the end when he couldn't
play that song
um and maybe one other time when the
songs when it just kind of stopped and
it didn't go into the next song right
and then I would have said that I think
for the most part everything else was
intentional which again is which is why
I'm saying that the
the style that you're embracing is kind
of like you can't really you can't
really go wrong you know that's right
it's as long as something
comes out
it was amazing I had such a good time
I'm not saying I did amazing I'm saying
it was an amazing experience like it was
just like just just I just putting it
out there and just the exuberance of the
crowd there wasn't enough room for me
everybody was facing the stage and
watching me and watching all of us On
Stage dance and kind of dancing in place
but it was kind of like a watching a
concert but it was just a DJ you know
yeah I've never I I guess that's what
happens when people go to like DJ
concerts like that you're there for the
DJ
yeah I guess so never been there either
that's that's the other thing is that
like I've never been to a club like
dancing and here I am trying to be a DJ
I might need to start going to clubs see
what they do but it's a different thing
like that's not the type of music I play
I think I'm more of a barbecue DJ
honestly uh wrong but I can I can I okay
I guess I guess what I'm thinking is
that
regardless of what you do because I know
you want to talk about your other
experience I have to tell you about the
next thing you did but
yeah
For Better or For Worse
anything that we do for the rest of our
lives
including your DJing
uh
the majority of people who are going to
be there to see it if they've made if
they heard about it happening and
they're showing up to see it they're
going to be coming to it because of
everything else that you have done up to
that point
right I mean let's just face it same
goes for me and my music it's not like
all of a sudden regardless of how well
either one of these Endeavors would go
it's not like unless we like go you like
you go to a festival where everybody's
there for a bunch of other reasons if
people are like L count snuggle baby is
doing a show tonight
the majority of people are gonna be
there I like link I I like link and I
also like to dance that's the Venn
diagram and so I'm gonna be there and so
I think that ultimately that's a
beautiful thing and what it means what
to me what that means is is that
with the exception of things like hey
I'll DJ your party people who I don't
know
but if you're like hey I'm gonna just do
this show virtually every time you step
into this onto the stage it's going to
be people who are showing up because
they want to see you DJ in the way that
you DJ at whatever point in the process
you're at so it's like okay you're two
oh I'm not a snuggle baby I'm not
stopping year two L count snuggle baby
is going to be
12 months more proficient at DJing than
year one but the people and that's going
to change the experience but the people
are there because they're just like I
just want to be there to see year two oh
account snuggle baby allow me to
illustrate
uh how wrong you are
so
they were oh I'm not I'm not telling my
dare I'm talking about I flew home on
Sunday and then the next day Monday was
Halloween
and I had agreed to DJ
Lando's Friends Halloween party but
that's consistent with what I'm saying
that's a different thing let me tell you
about it it was the most different thing
so it was
Lando's 12 year old like uh you know
group of sixth grader friends
and then uh their parents which we're
all friends because of football and then
the house that it was at uh Lando's
friend has a younger sister so all of
her friends were there and some of those
parents
so it was like how big of a crowd two
group uh probably probably 50 people but
then like how many middle schoolers
there were probably
um you know 15.
and they're all in costumes yeah they're
all in costumes because I'm gonna there
was like in the backyard they had like
one little speaker set up and then but
it was actually pretty pretty loud and a
dance floor set up okay got it and then
a little fog machine thing like uh Brian
the dad who's a friend of mine he like
said all this stuff up it's pretty cool
and then so like they were gonna play
music I was gonna DJ a little bit and
then they were gonna trick or treat and
then to come back and I was gonna DJ
some more and the dads go
trick-or-treating with the kids while
the moms hang out at the party
and I was like yes I'm gonna I'm gonna
DJ this I need to get some more
experience I bring my deck I set
everything up an hour ahead of time I
come back and then everybody starts
showing up and I start playing well hold
on what are you and are you in Elkhound
uh Garb yeah no I was not planning on it
but I couldn't have anyway because it
was on the truck coming back from Ithaca
okay so I I wore my camo outfit that I
actually had worn the day before at no I
had worn it two days before at the
mythicon brunch like my camo outfit but
you're still elk house snuggle baby at
this point I still am just no no no
yeah I was still L con snuggle baby but
I just wasn't in my Garb okay because I
didn't have it right right
um people did ask me who I was dressed
up as and I was like I wore this two
days ago
uh but I said okay I'm a camouflage
giraffe if you want me to be because if
you had your costume on people would
just think you had on a costume yep
that's an interesting thing about going
to a Halloween party which would have
been cool but I didn't have it okay I
decided I was going to play the music
and I was going to dance and I was going
to like act like I was fully committed
to it even if there wasn't any kids on
the dance floor and there weren't
but then middle school man middle school
middle school in front of their parents
in front of their parents it was like
the potentially most it could have been
very humiliating
and I I tested that theory
because like they're they're up there I
finally get them on the Dance Floor
uh uh and
they were you know they were I didn't
play my speech how'd you get them on the
Dance Floor
I think I I think I played some Harry
Styles
you know you play a little bit of uh
late night talking get them out there
and then I had a stack of Post-it notes
and I said hey guys uh if you have any
requests write them down and they got
excited so they started writing down
stuff and I'm looking at the Post-it
notes and then it was like baby shark
I'm like are you freaking kidding me I
told you that was gonna happen I mean
like
Dancing Queen I'm like oh okay yeah man
you gave the control to a bunch of
middle schoolers and I well I didn't
give him control I said I'm not playing
any of the requests yeah you denied it
all and this one girl and this is the
younger girls came out of me and she
just kept saying
I I told you to play sexy and I know it
when are you gonna play sexy and I know
it and I was like I'll play it next this
is like and then I played sexy and I
know it and uh they loved it and then
they were moving and I was like okay
I gotta play by their rules and I put on
Dancing Queen and they were just I don't
know what it is about dancing queen but
they went nuts yeah they went middle
school they're going nuts over that
and
I was like yes I have them you know I
this was like my third or fourth song in
a row yeah that kept them on the dance
floor baby shark and then I ain't doing
no baby shark and then all of a sudden
they're like they're like draw the line
they're like they're like
having the time of their lives singing
along and then and I'm just standing
back there just like singing hey ah this
is working yeah I'm taking a requests
I'm a little embarrassed but it's
working and um then all of a sudden
the Music Stops
like and I looked down and like my USB
had been tweaked and it had come
disconnected and there was no because
you know and then it had to reboot so
like all these kids just like turn and
they're like oh I was odd by 17 middle
schoolers
and I was just like all I could do is
like make a face and go I it wasn't me
something happened to my computer your
computer died and then no the USB came
disconnected so my deck disconnected and
then when you reconnect it it has to you
have to restart the program
oh I mean this is like a you know
they were they were gone it was like
they disappeared from the dance system I
lost them I literally lost them I did I
couldn't even see them
where are the middle schoolers that I'm
trying my best to plead what mode does
elk count snuggle baby go into when that
happens there needs to be a third mode
defeated mode
I mean panic mode
snuggle baby enters panic mode no no I
gotta get D get uh Jenna to say that no
yeah I was fully prepared
okay you know
I was definitely prepared for that and I
was I made up my mind I'm like this is
this could be
soul-crushingly humiliating and I'm not
gonna let that happen
we went trick-or-treating had a good
time we came back I was like I'm gonna
redeem myself I'm gonna play some music
got him back on the dance floor and then
like they were running off other people
and then the parents some of which are
like good friends of mine got on the
dance floor and they were like all right
DJ let's have this and then I was like
they put me on the spot I'm like I gotta
play something now I got to figure out
how to make better get back my friends
dance
and uh
I played a song
and they didn't like it oh these are my
friends they they weren't even humoring
me and then uh I played another song
they didn't like it and then I like I
was like all right I just I have to I
have to Pander I gotta play like Party
in the USA I just gotta go well you know
that was one of those one of the
observations that I made because I never
ever I like the song I've never thought
about a DJ before until you did it like
other than like are they playing hard
but one of the things that I was able to
observe even in a really supportive
crowd like all the mythical beasts is
that if you could put two songs you know
you could show me two songs and BPM is
the same uh perceived like energy is the
same yes and I would be like yeah both
of these are like crowd hype inducing
songs and then it turns out that for
whatever intangible reason that it's
very difficult to anticipate no only one
of them is what the crowd is gonna like
right and that to me is what something
clicked that's when something clicked
for me is like oh that's really the the
job of a DJ they can't you know people
knowing what's going to happen yeah and
they're not gonna it's they don't wanna
fake it you know even my friends didn't
want to fake it and they were just like
come on place and I finally got him with
that and then I so I played a couple of
songs and I was like building momentum
and everybody was having fun and then
all of a sudden
um the same thing happened again
everything just died
and a woman
RH
or like 30 she's in her 30s that I did
not know oh no like she you know she had
an emotional reaction to the fact that
when they were finally getting into it
oh gosh I'm getting um this one my face
is getting rich this woman that I did
not know
like when the music just dies just whips
around and looks at me is like
dude God what come on she's like and I'm
like
oh he's like there's one thing for like
some middle school but like and you know
what I forgive her I lured her into a
trance of enjoyment that then I snatched
her out of it and all she could do was
just emote
at who the DJ that she didn't know for
all she knew it was the guy that was
paid to be there and where you sold
camera you certainly look like it I
didn't fit in with any of my many other
adults there you know so it's like that
that hurt man hold on see what happened
that time
I said I I'm I'm sorry it's my computer
what happened the USB that's connected
but how does that happen because I had
to raise up my laptop by putting it on
top of the suitcase that I brought my
deck in and the suitcase was empty and
it was a plastic shell suitcase and it
sagged in such that when the laptop
sagged in it disconnected the USB
adapter to my deck so it unplugged it
and it just slowly happens whenever like
if you bump the table or it doesn't let
Quest love have like a branded like lock
that you can put on your doesn't cable
doesn't any DJ worth his salt have like
a like a setup where that doesn't happen
I'm buying one a day
yeah this is this ain't gonna happen if
you buy one that at night but it dude
I'm gonna tell you
I went from
the best DJ experience that any DJ could
ever have
to one of the most humiliating like I
mean I might as well have been naked how
did you recover from that one I didn't
party over at that point well I I said I
apologize profusely and then I was like
I had also hooked up my phone to the
Bluetooth on speaker and I just started
playing music on my phone and I shut my
laptop oh gosh I shut my laptop and I
just started playing music from my phone
oh and I was so disappointed like I've I
was just so
I wasn't mad I wasn't
you know I was just disappointed you
know I wanted I wanted to be playing at
this point where was she she was like
just play some stuff on your phone and
then like when I started playing stuff
on my phone like kept dancing and it was
okay
and then I tried to skip to the next
song Why did you why did you skip that
song it's like they were they the people
were not letting up yeah yeah they were
like
you're also in Los Angeles like one of
the things that I've learned multiple
times
um is that so many people whether they
work in the entertainment industry or
they are so close to the entertainment
industry that's why most acts don't like
to perform at La because it's the
judgious even if they're your friends
it's the judgious crowd in the world
because this is like the center of
entertainment so the standards and the
way they look at everything you it puts
you in a really tough position I yeah I
just I mean I literally
I I I had to shut down my system I just
I it failed it literally failed and then
I'm just a dude playing songs from his
phone
but that did Salvage it
I mean I literally almost killed the
party
like those two times and then there were
two other times when I just bumped the
USB and it just stopped for like a
second there's another way to see this
that may be encouraging I have another
way I mean I have some conclusions but
go ahead is that you what you got was in
in this second party situation is you
were tangibly appreciating
the power
that you hold
as a DJ yeah I said it was more power
than I could wheel and it's this thing
like a toddler willing like a heavy
Steel song I think you know this is
chapter two of your Memoir you know
chapter one is your debut and it's
wonderful and right as soon as you get
out of the gate you you fall flat on my
face just like Jenna you run right off
my headphones uh but you're learning but
you're tough but the one of the lessons
is the the potential the power that you
have and it's just with great power
comes great responsibility man like
you're a DJ now there's no looking back
there's no looking back I mean elkhouse
knuckle baby cannot be put back in the
womb no he can't and you know what
that's exactly I was I was extremely
disappointed because I wanted I had
things I wanted to do and I couldn't do
them and but I I apologize to the host
and he didn't care at all like nobody
really cared like after that moment what
about that woman even the woman later I
talked to her and she pieced it together
that I was just another dad at the party
who was not being paid and she was like
I said you know it wasn't a big deal it
wasn't we I played music for my phone
for another hour just like I normally do
at get-togethers and uh it really was
fine I was just you know I I did have a
hard time
um that night and Christy helped me out
but you know what I'm I'm grateful for
both experiences and I'm grateful for
them being so close together because now
it's kind of like
they kind of Blended in a good way
that's like I can
I've had my highs I've had my lows
you know and now I'm just I'm gonna I'm
gonna pay my dues and I'm gonna work my
way back
up to the top baby yeah you're like
three years old in DJ years I I am so
grateful for both experiences because I
mean the second one was just so it was
just such a learning experience you know
if I would if I was a more diligent
researcher and planner and stuff like
that if I and then I probably could have
sidestepped some of it but sometimes you
just can't you can't replace a good life
lesson you know and
I am really excited I I mean it's
invigorating to put yourself out there
and do something especially when you
have people who can celebrate it and
then
but but even with even the other part
it's like putting yourself out there and
saying I'm I'm learning something new uh
I am really into it it's a really fun
hobby that can you know the TAPS in a
lot of my passions and I can connect
with people and it's something that I
can get better at
you know and I can I can have this I can
just have another Lane of creativity and
growth that is
um it's a different lane from from what
we do and you know I now I'm now
experiencing through through that a lot
of what we talked about that you also
experienced with James and the shame and
it's just it is invigorating and like
the good man and the Ugly of it you know
and being able to express myself and say
the the CR the strange very linkish
ideas I have
um I can just do it like I don't you
know I don't have to
uh
I can I can be fully myself and it and
there is a part of that that like
if we were doing this together
wouldn't it it would there would be some
push and pull right because it's like if
a double DJ yeah if we're doing double
DJ this would be a little weird now I
will say I I do I'm I
think I need to talk to Ben about being
part of my Elkhound snuggle baby costume
like I'm thinking about like we talked
about this like putting him in a Baby
Bjorn in front of me with like baby
antlers yeah and so then I can just like
fist bump for the crowd and then he he
and then he works the deck sometimes
yeah or whenever I can't figure out how
to play the next song why is it not
playing he just like stick he sticks his
head and arms out of my kangaroo pouch
and he does it for me and he goes yeah
yeah I don't want to do that no I think
Ben could do that yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask Ben if speaking of that that
is one thing that uh in the in the bit
that I watched Diplo last night
um one of the things that you did that
he didn't do is is a lot of this a lot
of the fist pumping I was dancing a lot
yeah yeah you got you're you're very
you're very active it's very good did I
except for the times when I was totally
bum fuzzled like you gave me notes at
the mythical party about the look on my
face what did you think about my
the way that I held myself as a DJ on
stage
um
I think you
yeah I don't think you ever looked like
you were lost even if you were now now
that I know that you were at certain
points yeah but there were a couple of
times when I when I could kind of see
that there was this like
um
link has a look on his face right now
that is there it's hiding something
that's going on underneath I didn't know
it was that oh you were pressing a
button and something else was happening
I think it was more like you were like
questioning your entire life right now
yeah but no I yeah I I a huge
improvement from uh the uh the mythical
party uh you know the glass is hell
uh yeah they do you know it's my wreck
I'm Gonna Leave You with a wreck thank
you for
the love that you gave to Elkhound
snuggle baby
um thank you for spelling it with the
parentheses thank you for being here for
it even if you weren't there for it and
um you know there's gonna be more
there's gonna be more from Elkhound
snuggle baby he ain't going away
here's my wreck
um I gotta give you a song song I'm into
as of late
um which one am I going with
uh
Freddie Gibbs feel no pain featuring
Anderson pack I'm a big Anderson pack
fan and I I like the Freddie Gibbs album
Soul sold separately
I don't know anything about him as a
person
but as a rapper
I'm I'm a fan and this is that's an it's
an unexpected song that will take you by
surprise
didn't mean to start playing anything
right now yeah so um feel no pain there
you have it right there
thanks for joining us El count snuggle
baby out continue the conversation with
us hashtag ear biscuits and also
remember you can always call and be a
part of the conversation 1-888 earpod
one
so I miss Starbucks free stuff or
Starbucks partner
um and we have a Reddit thread called
Starbucks partners and it's so funny
because I was going through our like
hottest posts and one of them like one
of the most popular posts on that Reddit
um group is link a baristo
um selfie with link saying if anyone
sees link get them a grande I latte with
oat milk and I just think it's so funny
and I wanted to share it because you
guys need to know especially a link that
Starbucks braces love you there you go
thank you guys have a great day hi Rhett
and Link this is Courtney
um I love listening to your podcast
especially the awkward encounters link
has in his social situations but as I
was laughing at the embarrassing things
he does I realize that I am inclined to
do similar things the other day I was at
the store and this mom was unloading her
car onto the conveyor belt she's at the
register and her four-year-old daughter
was crying and begging for her mom to
buy her this gum and I don't know what
inclined me to be so helpful but when
her mom was busy unloading I made icons
attacked with the little kid and I just
shook my head quietly hoping the little
kid would get the message of you know
don't be a brat like your mom said no
and I was trying to help out the mom
while she wasn't looking but did this
stop the little kid no it was just
really awkward as we were looking at
each other and I shook my head and I
told my husband about this and he was
like why did you do that so I don't know
what this inclination is to do these
awkward things but I can relate love you
guys hey this is Braden from Tacoma
Washington just wanted to call and say
that I've been watching you guys since I
was in elementary school
um and it's really cool how how much you
guys have grown and I just really
appreciate that you guys are so open
that your biscuits podcast is by far my
favorite podcast
um it's funny that you guys always touch
on stuff that I'm like going through or
like uh like dissecting in my own life
around the time that I'm doing that so
it's like I don't know man it feels
special I know it's not for me
throughout everyone but it feels very uh
very targeted so you guys are doing a
great job just want to say thank you
again Rhett and Link and all the team
over at uh Good Mythical just keep it up
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]